[Music]
hey what's up on today's show we're
going to be talking about daddy issues
dads of adult kids
dads of little kids we're going to be
talking about the importance of
premarital counseling and getting on the
same page with values
we're going to be talking about election
anxiety the stress
and here's the thing i don't normally
tell people who i vote for but people
all over the world are asking me who i'm
going to vote for so i'm going to tell
you right now
i'm voting for
[Applause]
hey what's up i'm john and this is the
dr john deloney show
we're taking your calls about your life
about your relationships about
your dilemmas the goal of this show is
to help you rethink
re-examine reconsider your lives how you
talk to yourself how you talk to your
kids
how you talk to those you love how to
honor those
that you don't like how to unhook the
chains of those who've hurt you
and give you next steps for the rest of
your life my goal is
to help take you through mental health
challenges relationship challenges
the confusing always changing science
these basic ways of living
that have been way over complicated way
distilled down and three talking points
or
four little fancy ways to way over
professionalized super far removed from
normal people like you and me
we talk about love loss gut-wrenching
decisions
confusing moments or we may talk about
one of my greatest pet peeves on the
entire planet
i don't get angry very often it's just a
waste of time and energy
i especially don't get raged out very
often but one thing that makes
my insides boil like they're on fire
is when i see someone at a crosswalk who
doesn't wave
when i'm in a in a car which is a giant
2000 pound metal missile and i stop
and somebody's got little earbuds in and
they walk along as there's no
human interaction as though they are a
snowflake
and i am i don't know i'm just a bush
i'm just a tree in the forest not worthy
of
eye contact or a wave you want to change
the world people
wave at one another at crosswalks
acknowledge that the person
sitting in their giant metal suv could
run you over
even in their tiny plastic prius they
could run you over
but they don't because they're kind it's
against the law but they're kind
right and acknowledge they're a human
and that you're a human
and they are worth a little wave you
want to make a difference
you can vote yes you can um
feed the homeless you can help one
another yes but start with a wave
when you cross a crosswalk look and make
eye contact and wave
anyway whatever's going on in your heart
mind or universe give me a call i'm here
to walk with you
call me at 1-844-693-3291
that's one eight four four six nine
three three two nine one or you can
email me at ask
john ramseysolutions.com ask
john ramseysolutions.com and i wanna
start today's show
not going directly to the phones we've
already got calls lining up this is
awesome
but i have a buddy staying with me today
um this week actually he's staying with
me and my wife
um here in nashville and man we got to
talking on my front porch last night
about election stuff
and the economy and
voting and all of the things and things
and things
and i felt my blood pressure going up i
started talking too much and talking too
much and i'm sure
all of the internet apps are recording
all of my conversations i'm having with
my friend on my front porch
and i was just getting more like and i
thought
dude stop every every day you go out to
talk to people on the radio you talk to
people in person
and tell them to chill out control what
they can control
right anxiety is just an alarm system
well here's the deal
anxiety is an alarm system it's goes off
when you're scared it goes off when
you're disconnected it goes off when you
can't control the future
and that's where we all are right now in
a couple of weeks we're going to vote i
don't know when this show is going to go
out but
when you hear it it'll be right up
against voting time
and voting makes us feel small elections
make us feel
small because here's why when we control
the things we can control
we realize that we just have one thing
that we can do
it's like going to the circus and you're
throwing ping-pong balls into those
fishbowls and you're trying to get that
little goldfish
and when we're voting we get one
ping-pong toss that's it
and november 7th is going to come and go
and there's nothing we can do to change
the date there's nothing we can do
to change the outcome other than cast
our one vote and here's the deal
you have to vote you have to
i don't want i don't care you have to
it's a part of being a citizen it's a
part of
of participation it's a part of taking
ownership in
your day your kids day your life your
future
i continue to be moved by memories of
pictures tv shots of countries
throughout my lifetime who have gone
from
various political regimes to democracies
however flimsy and
hard and wobbly those democracies are
but seeing the
lines down the blocks of people who
finally have an opportunity to be heard
to talk and it's just a big deal
you got to participate right so if
you're feeling anxious if you're feeling
nervous
here's a couple of things you can do
to deal with the election anxiety number
one make a decision you're gonna vote i
just made it with you
we're all gonna go vote number one uh or
number two
limit your media intake by now you know
you know who you're voting for period
you are not thinking i don't know maybe
uh maybe uh
ah man voting day is november 3rd james
child's in there not november 7th
it's november 3rd um so yeah voting down
november 3rd you guys got that but
here's the deal you already know you're
going to vote for you know
there's nobody in america right now
going i don't know you know
so that means you don't have to keep
watching that means you can turn off
your
your any of your devices i love this
term uh
doom scrolling where you're just going
there looking for things that are going
to make you anxious to get you that
that cortisol hit right um to get you
that
anxious feeling that hurt your heart
rate up a little bit if you need your
heart rate up go have some coffee
go have some coffee but just turn it off
you know who you're going to vote for
decide locally if you want to get some
more information if you want to learn
about some
things you can do locally in your area
which by the way is where you have the
most impact
ask about your local candidates read up
on them read about them talk to people
um in your community about them
that's where you're gonna you know maybe
have some ideas i didn't know about this
judge i didn't know about this
representative
but think about things you can do
locally and then create a plan for how
you're gonna get involved one of the
things i'm going to do in my house is
i'm going to take my son with me when i
go vote
and that might mean i've got to get him
out of school depending on when i can
get out of here but i want him to see
the lines
i want him to sit in that line and he's
10 it's going to be painful for all of
us
all the people in my community can be
painful for but i want him to have
memories seared into his mitochondria
that his dad stood in a long long line
because this was a big deal i want him
to remember how important this moment is
and then make time to rest and play to
laugh to be with your community to kick
a soccer ball around
to otherwise be a human being that's
what you can control
you get one vote you get one ping pong
ball into the fishbowl and that's it
do what you can do and put the rest down
mindlessly scrolling
who won this we all saw the debate we
saw who won right
we saw who won no one right so we all
let's just move on let's let's do our
vote let's
learn about what's going on locally
let's be with one another as human
beings
let's wave at crosswalks and let's try
to regain our humanity
in the next few weeks and then whoever
wins
we're still gonna pump gas next to one
another we're still gonna
share meals next to one another in
restaurants we're still gonna
wave to each other at crosswalks let's
regain our humanity and let's not go on
the offensive let's not go on the curl
up in a ball let's move forward together
united is one group of people trying to
do the best we can
all right that's it that's my election
rant um that's it all right so let's go
to
let's start off today we're gonna go to
let's go to tyler in minneapolis
tyler good morning how are we doing good
man
doing well how are you john outstanding
how can i help you this morning
so i'm 17 years old and i'm in a junior
in high school
uh i i just feel like i'm starting life
too early i started listening to
mr ramsey when i was just turning 16 i
really got into
financial stuff and life's choices i put
an idea in my mind that i had to live my
life
perfectly or i wasn't going to be
successful
and i don't know if i should just let
loose a little bit and
have some fun in high school or keep my
head down and
keep doing my thing well number one
thanks for calling man are you skipping
class right now
no i'm actually i got contact trace so
uh so you're at home anyway
okay right so number one congratulations
for being a
junior in high school who pays attention
to the world around them that makes you
different than i was when i was a junior
i was just trying to play rock music and
play sports
and that was about it so good for you um
when you think when you say am i
like starting too early to live my life
what do you mean by that
well i just feel like i'm making really
adult decisions and not hanging out with
friends and
um like doing
doing wiser stuff that normal teenagers
aren't doing
and i feel out of place with everybody
else and
i don't have many friends because of
that so it's just
it's hard to talk to people about stuff
sure so
let's drill down on that a little bit
because having friends
and doing fun silly things and laughing
a lot
is not against being an adult
right i have a lot of laughter built
into my day we do silly things we were
pranking each other the other day
backstage at an event here in nashville
um we are constantly laughing with the
radio team behind the booth here i mean
um i like to build silliness into my
life
i also have to show up on at work on
time right i got to get my assignments
done
i've got to pay my bills and things like
that so those aren't mutually exclusive
what's making you feel like you are
wiser than the people around you or you
are i don't say superior but you're
doing more adult things than they are
does it have to do with smoking
cigarettes staying up too late eating
unhealthy food like what are the things
that you're talking about
well yeah it's like i don't do any drugs
or smoking i don't
drink it all and i feel a lot of the
people around me do that
and i i know i heard
somebody say the other day that what's
the point of
driving as a teenager if you can't drive
stupid
but i drive safe and i'm like i don't
i don't get that so yeah that those are
nonsensical goofy statements that a few
loudmouth knuckleheads we'll put out
there but that the majority of people
don't
in reality live by so i'll give you some
peace of mind i've worked with high
school students and college students
and even graduate students for years and
years and years almost two decades
actually more than two decades and we
used to do this thing called social
norming
tyler and what social norming was
is we would give people real data about
what's actually going on in the lives of
the people around them
and so when you're 17 and you don't do
drugs
you're 17 and you don't drink you're 17
and you just like to get your homework
done and listen to some music and watch
a funny show at night and then go to bed
and you're not on the football team and
you're not in band
and you're you actually like
reading you actually like writing it's
easy to feel like you are in a vortex
that you are all alone that you're the
only person because all you hear is the
loud people in those
high school hallways all you see is the
the caricatures on whatever
tv show that's depicting high school
kids or college kids
here's the reality i used to give these
statistics i would do
these big surveys of students and it
would always come back
regardless of where i was way
way fewer people were actually drinking
than people thought
way fewer people were actually dating
and hooking up than people thought
way way way fewer people were actually
doing drugs than people thought
and so what happens is a whole bunch of
people listen to these caricatures they
listen to the loudmouth in the group
or in their class or in the hallway and
they begin to feel small
they watch these tv shows they watch
these movies and they begin to feel like
that's not me that doesn't depict me
and i want you to know there are way
more people in your school
there's way more people in your
community there's way more people in
your
state that are just like you tyler
now are they listening to dave ramsey
trying to figure out how to start saving
money
as a 17 year old not a bajillion of them
right
there's a lot of adults who aren't doing
that so that makes you unique already
which is awesome
but i want you to not walk down the hall
wondering
am i the only one nobody's like me
and i want you to walk with your head
held high and say i get to choose how
i'm living my life
i get to choose the things that make me
happy
those things don't make me happy i don't
have any interest in them and i'm a
person of value
and my promise to you tyler is there's
other people just like you
so at school are you involved in any
activities are you involved in any
after-school events
or teams or anything like that
yeah well i'm in sports i'm in football
and baseball but i'm also in
um choir and our drama club
and our show choir as well dude very
cool man so you're getting to see it all
i did that too i've played sports i
in high school and college i was in
choir in high school i did
theater in college i'm going to tell you
right now
you are going to feel a little bit weird
i did right i remember sitting
at football like games and i loved my
teammates and they would be like
screaming in rah-rah
and they didn't always understand what
was happening and then in choir
there's people that were like to the
death choir right
they made they were just like those
those kids on glee like they were in
it to win it i never fully got that
either
i loved acting in theater and those kind
of things but there was
people who were infinitely more talented
than me that lived and breathed
that um so you're going to always feel a
little bit weird tyler and i want to
tell you that's a good thing you're
getting a wide breadth of experiences
you're meeting
all kinds of cool different wacky fun
interesting people
and that's going to make your life
richer when you get out of high school
and you get into college and you start
seeing different folks and having
different experiences your whole world's
going to open up
and so tyler i want to give you some
peace about who you are and where you
are
if you're having fun and you love choir
and you love playing baseball
you love playing football you love
acting
do it all do all of it
get your homework turned in and then one
day if you don't like playing baseball
anymore don't play baseball anymore
but don't give up on you don't give up
on your values don't start feeling like
i got to start doing these things
because i'm like them or
don't start backing away from people
because you just assume they're doing
all these things because i
promise you tyler i promise you you're
not the only one there
and as it goes to dave's stuff man the
earlier you can start thinking about
money
the earlier you can start thinking man i
got to go to college in a few years
maybe i should start saving money for it
maybe i should talk to my parents about
it
the earlier you can make a decision that
i'm not going to
shackle myself to a credit card or to
debt and that's gonna
hang over me and inform my relationships
and my decisions for years and years and
years and years down the road
the earlier you can do that brother you
are gonna feel weird you're gonna be out
on an island
but you are setting yourself up for a
lifetime of success
that's going to differentiate you from
all people around you so tyler
i'm high-fiving you from nashville to
minneapolis
i hope that you do not have covid i hope
that your
contract traced isolation is going to
end with a smile on your face
and i want you to go back to school with
your head held high walk down the hall
with your
head held high i want you to be
intentional about making friends and
meeting people and getting connected
with folks
and double down on friendships my man
double down on friendships they're worth
it and you're worth it
all right let's go to micah in houston
micah good morning brother how we doing
doing well how are you outstanding
outstanding so how can i help you this
morning
so when i was 18 my dad
left our family and moved in with his
mistress
um at that point i kind of told him
that i she wasn't part of my life but
his life and i had nothing to do with
her
and fast forward to the two today i'm 21
and he texts me and my brother that they
are now getting married and he's kind of
been forcing
upon us that she's a part of his life
now in order to be with him
we need to meet her and i still haven't
met her
and have been recently being conflicted
on if
i'm doing all i can as far as even
accepting him and who he is and also
sharing the love of christ
and to um his situation
and if i'm in the wrong or not for still
holding
what i said before not meeting her hmm
so why haven't you met her yet
um so one i never had the opportunity
like at the very first
of it um it just wasn't a thing and i
was kind of oblivious to the affair
you're 21 now so why haven't you reached
out just to meet her 21 now
yeah why haven't you reached out in the
last year too and this isn't a judgment
question this is just me
digging in why haven't you just decided
hey i need to meet this lady she's been
with my dad for three years now
part of it from what i've heard of other
people
and that have known her in the past i
know i probably shouldn't
yeah i don't care what other people say
why haven't you reached out
you're 21 you can drink and drive that
sounded bad
you can drink period you can drive
period you can buy guns period
why haven't you why haven't you reached
out to her you're an adult now
i've just always had an
uncomfortableness about it okay
i've never had been out of peace how has
your relationship with your mom changed
um we have groton a whole lot closer
okay um i've saved she's had some
medical issues
from all the stress and stuff and it's
been a lot of
yeah supporting her and her supporting
the family
so your dad's getting married soon and
you're in this
weird spot do you still talk to him
outside of this outside of his recent
text message which is how children
communicate with one another by the way
um it's i would say it's embarrassing
and it's frustrating that your grown
father chose to
drop this on you via text message but
that's for
that's for another show um how has your
relationship with him been
outside of him leaving your mom and
finding somebody new do y'all talk
regularly do you talk on the phone do
you all have lunch together how does
that how do y'all interact
um we interact on the phone and with
lunch
it's very sporadic um
because sometimes it really can be it's
just easier
um to love him from a distance sure and
let him reach out to me
um going to school working
and when i have too much contact with
him or i'm talking with him
um regularly there's a lot of arguments
that go back to
needing to meet her and him justifying
all of his decisions
and me you know saying that
i don't agree here and stuff and him
just trying to prove why he's right and
everything and how he's still in god's
will
and talking about you know
trying to correct me as a christian too
so let's let's
put mom down and let's put dad down and
i want to take you in a spaceship and
let's go up 30 000 feet
above this situation okay okay so
there's a guy
who made your mom cry he hurts your mom
right when you're an 18 year old young
man
he hurt your mom and he's continued to
hurt your mom for the last three years
so you're going to have a natural
built-in
extended middle finger to the guy that
hurts your mom that's
natural and that's normal okay and
you love this guy called your dad
and in whatever weird way it sounds like
he's still
in some broken fumbly way
loves you and still tries to connect
with you and still tries to reach out
he's still desperate for your
affirmation right he still wants you to
make sure this is all okay for him
because he's still conflicted
but he's still your dad and you still
love your dad and it's okay to still
love your dad even if he hurt you
and so what you need to do is this your
dad
is a grown man of his own and he's
allowed to do whatever he wants to do
right wrong or indifferent
what i will tell you is every marriage
has things that goes on behind closed
doors that are hard
and ugly and messy and challenging
and you will probably never fully get to
the bottom
of what was in your dad's heart what was
in your mom's heart what 20 years or 30
or 40 years of them being married was
like
you'll never know you'll also never come
around to the fact that what your dad
did was okay
right that's never gonna be something
you make peace with
and so what you've got to do is put down
your thoughts about what my dad's doing
what his
new wife is doing you get put all that
down and you have to make decisions
grown-up adult decisions
for you micah
you've got to decide who you're going to
be and what character is going to look
like for you
and so less about how can i should i do
this
for him and should i be it are you going
to be a guy
and these aren't judgment questions
again i'm just asking questions to for
you to think through these
this is going to be a loyalty issue
about you and your mom can i love my dad
and still love my mom
is it am i going to be abandoning her am
i going to be being disloyal to her if i
go to this wedding
if i go meet this other lady right um
are you going to be disloyal and abandon
your dad
who walked away from you guys right are
you going to abandon your dad if you
never decide to meet her
you're you've got to own the legacy of
these conversations these are character
decisions for you my man
and so when i want to ask you put your
dad's stuff down put your mom stuff down
what do you want to do micah
okay no i'm asking you
what do you want to do um
i i want a relationship with my father
so he has told you you can have a
relationship with me in one way and one
way only and that's if you fully accept
this new woman
and you meet her and you make her a part
of your life too because you don't get
me without her
and he's a grown-up and he's drawn that
boundary you may think that boundaries
nuts
it may be immoral it may be violates
your faith
like your religious codes but that's the
boundary he drew
and your mom may have drawn a boundary
which is if you loved me
you will never talk to that woman
and now you're a 22 year old man stuck
in the middle of other people's
boundaries
which is where we all find ourselves all
the time so i'm asking you
not what about him what do you want to
do
um
i i want to have
my own life apart
a part of immorality and being able to
raise my own family
the way that i see the lord is leading
me to raise them
okay can you be in contact and in
relationship with people who choose
different values than you
or does that mean they're you're done
with them
no i can't you can't what
i can be in contact with you you can
okay
yeah so my question to you and you're
you're telling this to everyone who's
listening to this podcast which may be
like 18 people
if we're being honest right um
will you go to that wedding or are you
gonna tell your dad
i simply can't accept your new wife i
can't accept that
i still love you as my dad but i can't
be a part of that
wedding or are you gonna go to the
wedding
and say dad i think this whole thing's a
mess and tell
his new wife you are my dad's new wife
i don't like how any of this happened
i'm going to respect you as a person
i don't approve of this i don't like
this but this is the life that
the cards i've been dealt and you're
going gonna go to your mom and say mom
you're my mom and i love you and dad's
my dad and i love him
however crooked and messy this whole
thing has gotten i'm gonna love you both
the best i can
which one of those sounds right in your
heart
probably going to the wedding and
talking about how it's not right but i'm
still loving both of them
okay what's your mom going to say about
that conversation
she's going to be in support of it okay
do you feel at peace with moving on
towards honoring relationships even if
you don't buy in
what's going on behind closed doors even
if your values on the front end say i
don't like this
are you at peace with that yes i am
man a whole lot more i usually don't
think i do a lot of good on this thing
but i think we got somewhere today micah
way to go man
hey here's the thing i do too thank you
listen you're 21
and i want to just give you some really
great slash not great news
this is the rest of your life
i really want this job but it's in this
city
i really want to marry this person
but they want to live in this town
i want to have six kids they want to
have two
i want to have dogs they want to have
cat this is the rest of your life
i want to go to this church you know she
wants to go to that church
i want to have this kind of friend he
doesn't want to
that's the rest of your life and so what
often we get sucked into
is how can i help this person especially
with our parents
kids get really round up in how can i
make my dad feel okay
how can i stand my ground hold my values
be my own person and also make sure my
dad's feeling okay
and so if you can have this hard
conversation with yourself
with your faith values with your mom
with your dad if you can start having
these hard conversations now brother
micah
the rest of your life is going to look
very different because you're going to
get to own
what you want what your boundaries are
what your values are
and then you're going to own those hard
conversations done in dignity and with
respect and with love
you're not going to be ugly to his new
wife if you choose to meet her
you're going to say hi you're a person
you came into this situation it's a mess
i would have preferred this not be this
way but you're a human i'm going to
treat you with dignity and honor
i'm going to be kind to you and i'm not
going to be disrespectful
i'm not going to become the guy that i
watched my dad become
and i'm going to talk to my mom and be
honest with her and
that's going to let you live your life
with dignity and with respect
hold your values and if your values end
up being you know what i'm not going to
sweating i cannot support anything about
this i think it's wrong
it violates every part of me then stand
up on
your own two feet with your head held
high and say these are my values this is
where i drew the line and these are my
boundaries
and you get to do that my man you get to
do that i'm not going to bail you out
and tell you what i think you should do
but you get to do that and i'm proud of
you for making hard
choices and for i it sucks for you being
a young kid put in the middle of this
trying to make your dad feel better and
trying to deal with a mom
who's sick and trying to remain loyal
that's hard but that's the rest of
all of our lives so good for you micah
i'd love to know what you decide to do
two weeks from now shoot me an email
back and we'll read it on the show here
i love to to hear back from folks when
they say hey listen i took two weeks i
took three weeks i did this and it's
been great or
i'm still struggling with something and
let's talk again so congratulations
micah good for you
let's go back to the phones let's go to
darcy in denver
darcy good morning how are we doing i'm
doing well john how
are you i am so good so good here in
nashville
so how can i help you this morning well
i have
um just a little advice that i need to
get from you
i have um a wonderful
six-year-old boy and a delightful
four-year-old girl
and um we just moved out of
my marital home with my husband it was
an abusive relationship
and excuse me we
um we just moved out five weeks ago and
what i'm struggling with the most right
now is
my my son's feelings towards his father
um i'm trying to give them time with him
with their dad um and because of what
has happened in our home prior to us
leaving
neither one of my kids want to spend
time with him at all
my son is to the point where
he will just tell me mom i hate him so
much
i don't want to see him um he said i
don't want to see him until november mom
i just don't even want to talk to him
and
he's very emotional
he has almost had panic attacks getting
ready to go see him
um is your son is your son safe
he is safe now yes but i mean when he
goes and visits
your ex-husband he's he's going to be
safe right
yes and this is the thing when the kids
go see their dad
they're with me i'm with them when
because if i try to leave they both
start crying
they and you know my husband doesn't my
soon-to-be ex-husband just he's not
he's not empathetic to what they're
feeling um
and our son has really experienced a lot
of resentment from
his dad because of just his own
childhood he did not have a great
childhood
and so he sees me as this doting mom on
our children and i think he resents
that his son gets the childhood he never
got
so i'm stuck here with
my own feelings and i'm trying to
validate
and acknowledge our son's feelings um
that he doesn't want to go see him
that his dad has hurt us but he's trying
to make things
right and is you know doing all the
things i wanted him to do
before we left um and so he's like well
why do we have to go see him but you
don't
have to go see him right so so
i just i don't know so let's let's
number one thanks for being vulnerable
here this is a mess
and i i just want to acknowledge that
sucks
okay yeah that's not how marriages are
supposed to be that's not how dads are
supposed to be
and um i know that's not the picture you
had drawn up and i hate that for you
um so a couple of different things here
number one
i would do the best i could to get out
of my soon-to-be ex's head
okay why he's choosing to do things now
as opposed to later he's doing this
because he resents me because
he i'm giving my kid the childhood he
never had they call that the fundamental
attribution here when you get into
somebody's head and you start deciding
why they're doing things or why they're
not doing things i would just stay
completely out of that
that's going to make you crazy number
one because you're going to always be
guessing
and then you start assigning motives to
why he did something why he didn't
he took them out for ice cream oh cause
he knows i don't like sugar and my kids
it's just gonna make you nuts and the
second thing is it's gonna
it's gonna be a cheap way to prop you up
and over the next
five weeks five months five years you're
going to get really exhausted
and you're going to get real frustrated
and you're going to grieve the loss of
this picture that you had with him
as the dad of these two beautiful little
kids you're going to get
resentful you're going to get heavy and
this is just going to be a cheap way to
prop you up by putting thoughts in his
head and then absorbing those thoughts
back into yourself it's just weird
feedback loop so what i want you to do
is just
leave his head alone you've got enough
weight in your own right now right
okay so here's a way i want you to think
about kids
and um i i kelly let me know about this
call coming today so i actually called
my friend
um in texas um
she is a rock star when it comes to
having hard conversations with children
this is what she does
and um i called her about a few calls
she is brilliant and i kind of asked her
through how do you have this
conversation how do you
talk to kids about these situations and
here's what she said
she said um kids look at themselves as
50
mom and 50 dad okay
and when parents get separated and a and
a
spouse talks bad about their ex um
gets real flinchy around their ex
especially if they're safe
says i know we've got to go do this then
the kid starts to
dislike or hate 50 of themselves
they begin to internalize these feelings
in ways that they can't understand
and so um what lin dr lynn jennings
she's the
she's the rock star who helped me think
through this but
over time when they internalize 50
bad then the way they justify 50
yelling at people 50 smashing things 50
doing drugs 50 sleeping around is
because i am that person
this kind of behavior is what i saw it
is who i am
and it justifies it in their head and it
also gives them some
numbing um it helps compress that pain
they feel from that disconnection from
that other person
and that's how addictions become
generational right it's just kids trying
to backfill the gap of
i'm not good i am disconnected and it's
my fault
and so when a five-year-old or
six-year-old
asks why don't you have to i say cause
i'm an adult
okay and you're a kid um i i would say
something like
because he's your daddy and i'm gonna be
there
but your daddy loves you and daddy makes
some mistakes
i make mistakes but daddy loves you and
he is working really hard to love you
the best way he he knows how
and over time what's gonna happen and
this is again
this is all under the umbrella that your
kid's always gonna be safe and that your
husband's honoring your kids right
um it's going to be really tough for you
to continue to speak positively about
him and i
you got to for the sake of the young man
your son is becoming you've got to
and for the sake of the picture that
your son is trying to interpret he's
trying to interpret a guy who loves him
and he knows he loves them and also he
scares me to death
yeah and that's a conflicting hard place
for a six-year-old to be
yeah and so you've got to be real
conscious to take your pain and your
heart
and use that with your deal that with
your counselor not with your
six-year-old
yeah and that hurt of that other parent
your kids will carry around like a bag
of bricks
and so it may be to your soon-to-be ex
hey i'm going to circle back to you i'm
going to tell you we're going to have to
stay in communication because we're
we're still parents of these two
beautiful babies
and so i know you don't want to hear
this x and i know
that you don't like it when i tell you
this scares our son
here's just a recommendation on a way
that we could not scare him and he may
say oh my god
you'll know that all you can control is
what you can do
and you're gonna move forward with
dignity on this one right
okay yeah yep and the best you can
to not run him down as hard as that's
gonna be
and to say why do i have to go and you
can look at your son and say because
your daddy loves you
and i know that you love your daddy
and what about when he said this yeah he
scared us he wasn't doing good that day
but he's trying to do better and it may
you may have to clinch your fist behind
your back you know what i mean
um and it may be that you're doing the
hard thing and you're showing up too
just to make sure they get to see your
dad and yeah
i'm a big believer never given up on
somebody and he may turn himself around
and um he may get the help and care that
he needs that doesn't mean that y'all
are going to get back together does it
mean that you're going to live happily
ever after
in this family force him but it does
mean that he might still turn around and
be into being a good dad to your to your
kids
yeah right yeah and that's what i've
told him is
i just want him to be a better person
and a better dad
for the kids so is he willing to hear
that
matter he hears it i don't know if he
accepts it i think
he wants me back
more than he wants the kids if that
makes sense
absolutely well and i'm looking into it
i'm kind of probably looking more into
it but
you know i just he keeps saying i want
us to work
i want to work on us and i'm like i want
you to fix you first then i fix me
and then we can be better parents for
the kids and then
the worst case scenario is we go through
the divorce and we get divorced
or so darcy are you are you done
i am yeah okay and i've told him that
i know but i'm hearing an ellipsis in
your voice i'm hearing a
dot dot in your voice are you done
i think it's i am done okay
then i'm going to encourage you to go
down whatever roads you need to do to
make sure that happens
okay i feel like if just
talking to you for a few minutes on the
phone i'm feeling conflicting
i'm feeling conflict in your voice okay
and i can only imagine what your kids
are experiencing i can only imagine that
your husband thinks he's actually
like she keeps coming back and she's
bringing the kids
and that means i'm doing the next right
thing and that means this thing's gonna
so if you know there's a period at the
end of your sentence
then it can begin to be cruel to let
your husband live
in a myth okay right
yeah and so if you're done done done
then make it done done done okay
and i have told him that you know i am
done
that we've tried to work and
i find myself wanting to call him when
we go do things together just the kids
and i
and it's just like this cyclical like
emotional thing for our son
and you know and i'm like i have like
what is it in me
that wants him here and it's not even
that i want him personally it's i miss
that companionship
yeah he was your best friend he was
enough that you had
you grew two humans together and you
loved him and you probably
still do love him and yeah for whatever
reason whatever abuse happened and i
don't want to get into it but whatever
happened that said
this is it then this is it and at some
point you're going to have to grieve
the loss of that thanksgiving table that
y'all are gonna have
in 12 years that you had a picture of
already in your head
of your son and his weird girlfriend
that he brought home from
his freshman year of high school of
college and your daughter's
weird boyfriend at thanksgiving and your
husband making jokes that's not gonna
happen
yeah and the sooner you stop living into
that fantasy and grieve it and
weep bitterly over it and then begin the
grieving process
then then you start the the true
separation process then your husband's
got a chance to grieve and then your
kids don't live in this
weird tractor beam that they're in right
now okay
you you can't experience pain
and then automatically just shut off the
fact that you love somebody
you can't
that is the truth it just doesn't work
that way and i know it's so cool and on
on the hallmark movies it always works
that way but it's just not how it works
in real life
right i know yeah yep but hey i want you
to know
that we're rooting for you and praying
for you and thinking about you
it's gonna be hard to both deal with
your heart and speak positively about
somebody
as you separate from them as you
begin or continue the journey of raising
a young man and a young woman
that's going to be a lot right and so
i'm just
with all of my being darcy get some
people around you that you can walk with
you
cannot do this by yourself and i'd
recommend a good counselor
that will talk to you if you've got good
friends not that are like
yeah yeah not those friends but people
who will be honest with you
and say hey you're being ridiculous
today or who will just show up with
donuts you know what i mean um if you've
got a good
good church group in your community
whoever whoever is around you right
but find some folks that you trust and
you can hang on to because it's going to
be a rocky rocky season for a while
okay okay thank you call me back if i
can help um
we'll be rooting for you okay darcy
awesome thank you so much john
no thank you for being with us for
walking with us and for trusting me with
that one that one's gonna be tough
all right let's take one more quick call
let's go to kristen in oklahoma city
kristin what's happening hi dr d
i need some advice bring it on let's do
it
i am getting married in april and
um i brought up premarital counseling a
few weeks ago
and he was like now we don't need that
like we're fine it's not a big deal and
it kind of just swept it under the table
and but it's kind of important we have a
one-year-old daughter
and i would love to have a sound
foundation in our marriage we did things
kind of backwards but we're trying to
fix it
and i just don't know how to bring this
back up without being
like maggie like controlling and i'm
just kind of freaked out about it now
so why doesn't he want to go i don't
know he was like we don't need that like
no
nobody ever like it doesn't work it's
nothing that
is for us why do you want to go
i think we need it i think the other
well about a month ago
we were talking about bills we have
everything split down the middle except
for our cars and our phones
um and we were doing our bi-weekly
cash transfers back and forth back and
forth at the atm and i was like man i
can't wait
until we combine our finances and don't
have to do this anymore and he was like
what do you mean
i was like well when we get married
we're gonna combine our finances that's
what you
that's what you do when you get married
and he was like
uh i didn't no i don't think we're gonna
do that
and then i actually heard you i don't
remember where it was at but uh
i don't know if it was on the dave
ramsey so or not but you were talking
about
when you do get married you need to make
sure you
like your brain is healthy before you
start this thing so i was already
thinking about doing starting therapy
before that but then that kind of
brought it into a like a spotlight like
what else are we not thinking about that
is going to come in the next
you know a couple of years that we could
address now before we get married
that could it help us immensely kristen
i'm high-fiving you from national i'm
hugging you
i am covet-hugging you from nashville to
oklahoma city
um i think you're real wise here so
here's the deal
um pre-marriage counseling premarital
counseling is
it's it's wonderful it's
exceptional i recommend it for a hundred
percent of people who are considering
getting married
um it's not going to
um it's not
gonna fix any and all problems what a
good pre-marriage counselor does
is it just like you just mentioned it
brings up questions that people who are
getting married never even
thought of it brings up value statements
that are different than beliefs it
it brings up those things that we don't
talk about all the time or
you hear me talk a lot about the
difference between words and pictures
well you have a picture of a married
couple and they just share the same
account
and your husband has a picture of a
married couple where
wife pays all the bills and i use my
money for whatever i get good and dang
ready to
right and so there's different pictures
and what a good marriage counselor is
going to do is just walk you through
those conversations
so that they don't set your house on
fire
when you're trying to figure out a new
marriage yeah
i and you've got a one-year-old a
beautiful little baby
oh she's the best yeah she'll actually
be one on the 22nd oh that's so cool
congratulations so um i this is a bigger
deal to me than just the pre-marriage
counseling
you've just been in three minutes you've
told me of two big value issues
one is i want to do something that's
going to bring us together
he blows it off and says nah we don't
need to do that and the conversation's
over in his head
yeah that's less about the pre-marriage
count premarital counseling and more
about
whose voice matters in this relationship
are we both in this together
um what happens five years from now when
i want a third kid and he's like man
or my mom's sick and she needs to move
in nah
like it's it's gonna be it's it's a
deeper conversation about how we're
gonna relate together how we're gonna
work together how we're gonna be on the
same team
and that's a values issue then about the
money thing right you
you've heard me my friend dave ramsey
here all of us
talking about money is one of the top if
not the top
um stressor in marriages it's money
and y'all already launching out of the
gate not on the same page
yeah right that freaks me out man it
should it should it should be it should
be an alarm bell
yeah so what you need to do is sit down
and have a hard values conversation
and you can't do this when it's a tense
moment already it needs to be something
that you plan
and that you'll have a deep conversation
about and if he refuses to have a values
conversation
then you need to go meet with somebody
about what that means
for your future okay and that's a scary
proposition that's a proposition that
most people in your situation don't go
through with
because they say i've already got a kid
this already is what it is
we'll just figure it out later and i'm
telling you right now later doesn't come
so freaky man yeah it's changing the oil
on the car while it's already moving and
y'all are kind of already doing that too
you already lived together you already
have a child so you're already way down
the road here
um and so you are doing things a little
bit out of out of order right
about like or it's just the person i
want to be with and this is a good human
being do we share values
so you're down the road there um i have
a hundred percent confident y'all can
make this
not work you can make this spectacular
and extraordinary
but it's going to be my best friend but
there's just some things that were
there like he's real big on like what
kind of food do you want the wedding
i don't care yeah it's like well i want
you to care this is
not only just me it's our wedding you
know but some of those are
again those are values conversations
yeah so at my wedding
i i honestly in my heart did not care
what we were going to eat
i had a weird thing you know what i
cared about the some of the music
and so my wife said here's what i want
you to do and this is part of our values
right
she she gave me the the gift of i'm not
going to judge the fact i'm not going to
put on you you don't want to get married
you don't like us because you don't have
an opinion on the napkins
she knew my values were i love you i
really we could get married
in a gas station bathroom for all i care
i don't care right
and so and i valued her to say these
things do matter to you
let's do it and those again those are
values conversations i don't put stuff
on him her in that way and she honored
me in reverse
and vice versa i honored her in the
other ways but when it comes to values
conversations like you've got to be
there i was
that wasn't one i could be like i don't
even want to be there
that was something that was important to
her and that was one of my core values
is i want to honor her
in the best way that i can and so that's
what i'm talking about a premarital
counselor can do for you guys that's
what a good values conversation can do
for you guys
and but that's something you'll need to
do sooner rather than later
and so that's one that you plan ahead of
time and you tell them hey we're going
to have
a picture ceremony what we want our
wedding to look like but more important
what we want year one to look like
i wanna i want to do a i want us to get
together
for a couple of like uh everyone makes
fun of me on on the internet
um we're gonna get together for a long
breakfast one saturday we're gonna go on
a saturday a long saturday date and
we're just gonna paint a picture of what
the next five years is gonna look like
for us business-wise financially where
are we gonna live
are kids gonna be six in five years
uh oh that's crazy she'll be going to
school right we're gonna paint that
picture
and we're gonna talk about values we're
going to talk about who we are and then
we're going to work back that way
and it's important that you let him know
this is a big deal to me that we do
pre-medal counseling
it's a big deal that we get on the same
page values wise
and if he says i'm not doing that i
don't care about any of that
it doesn't work it's stupid as hard as
this is for me to say that's an alarm
for you
that should be a big flashing red neon
sign that says
in the future i may think things are
important and i'm going to get blown off
and that's when you've got to have
somebody that you can walk alongside
some people that you trust in your life
that you can have those hard
conversations about is this a
relationship worth moving forward with
i hope it is i think it is i've got
faith in this dude i think he's going to
be like all right man i didn't realize
it was such a big deal let's go do this
that's my hope i i stay comically
optimistic about things and so let's go
i'm rooting for you kristen and for your
fiance so as we wrap up today's show
man i feel like i speak in hyperbole a
lot i say it's the greatest of all time
this my friends is the greatest song
ever written
this song was so great that he just
named the album after the song
that's how good it was and some people
think the greatest songs ever written
were written in 1800s these
big rich hymns nope the 1600s
irish drinking songs with these
transcendent melodies
nope the greatest song ever written was
written in 1987.
it was released on a one-word album
and the name of this song is so good it
only needed one
word for the title in 1987 george
michael brought us
the song faith faith ladies and
gentlemen and he wrote
but i've got to think twice before i
give my heart away and i know all the
games you play because i play them too
i need some time off from that emotion
time to pick my heart up off the floor
oh when that love comes down without
devotion well it takes a strong man baby
but i'm showing you the door i know
you're asking me to stay safe please
please
please don't go away you say i'm giving
you the blues
maybe you mean every word you say can't
help but think of yesterday
and another who tied me down to lover
boy rules
because i gotta have faith the faith of
faith i gotta have
faith the faith of faith and then
there's just a lot of faith right
man i gotta have faith this is the dr
john dolone's show